the radicals always have to be the
victim they always have to be the victim
the radicals
are radical ruling class and whichever
group of people
is being used as a tool of that radical
ruling class they have to be the victim
they could be attacking you they could
be committing an act of murder they
still have to be the victim it is not
possible for disfavored groups in
America ever to be the victim
Christians conservatives white people
men at least men who know that they're
men those people can never ever be the
victims if they are attacked they had to
have brought it on themselves if they
are attacked the real tragedy is going
to be the blowback the blowback that
never seems to happen by the way but the
globe the hypothetical blowback against
whichever group
perform the attack